okay last one most famous one
you're a driving and you went some
directions so you use your GPS right
which implies there's a whole network of
satellites that are transmitting done
and we talked about GPS before okay so
I'm not going to go into great detail
but the important thing is that you
don't figure you know for instance this
has a GPS receiving in it it has a GPS
let me say that again a GPS receiver the
key here is that you know the vast
majority of what we think is satellite
technology is just one directional right
sorry I had to say it simplex right this
thing doesn't have the power to send
something off to space okay it wouldn't
get there it's just receiving signals
and based on the different timings of
signals that it gets from different
satellites that's how it knows where it
is it's how it calculates to position
okay now alternatively if you did want
to send if you wanted to transmit data
to a satellite for instance if you had a
an internet connection through satellite
you would need a really really big
powered device to actually take that
okay you're also probably need like a
satellite dish dish which is you know
just a big receiver on top of your you
know top of your house my father might
pick my in-laws have this kind of thing
because these these signals are not that
strong
right because they're coming from so far
away and so you need something
sophisticated law to send or receive
those kinds of signals okay